he is the founder of the black Santa
company after 13 seasons in the
Association Baron Davis good to see you
back here in the program you bet you bet
what do you think is the the topic of
the NBA the biggest story of the NBA
through the first month and a half of
the season we got Christmas right around
the corner in the same way that you know
the season doesn't really begin in the
NFL until after Thanksgiving it's
usually around Christmas when rosters
are already set you're already yeah
you're start tuning in the chemistry is
already working or it's not yet work and
so what do you think is the biggest
story so far you know I would probably
have to defer to you because I would say
that you know you've been in the daily
grind
since the season started I myself have
not you have not been tapping in you
know just kind of like I think over all
these storylines that have been more so
pop culture are just like I feel like
our fluff pieces like where's the real
like what's the real story okay so let
me give you choices the seven loss month
of November for Golden State that
included draymond Green getting
suspended by the team because he dropped
the b-word on Durant for giving him
grief for having a son okay not a big
deal Steph Curry was out that's not a
big deal but that's a big deal in terms
of this this clearly will be Durant's
last season there cuz he you know how
many fights teammates get into and
people on the same team get into that's
like come on man that's that's like
nobody's even talking about it anymore
that was like a lot that was like
whatever it happened it was blown up
that week after they both came out you
know and said what they have to say in
February it's not gonna matter March
April May July I mean June right and in
July when you know they're competing
June when they're competing for a
championship it's not gonna matter so
you're thinking that maybe Steve Kerr
and the rest of the team's thinking if
if the impending free agency for Durant
was a problem in the mind's eye of
draymond Green or maybe the rest of the
team he was giving voice to at least
they got it out of the way in a
meaningless
in Staples Center and they're popping up
in man is you play pick-up ball in the
summer right you want the last shot you
HOT you know I take the ball and then I
dribble and I'm you know I turn the ball
over you're gonna be hot we're gonna get
into a heated exchange I wanted to win
you want to win so that's just taking
place on the highest level but I don't
think it's too much to put too much
weight into especially into the seven
losses because you know they kind of
need it that you know a lot of times
when you have a team in a machine like
that that is moving and you know moving
the way they've been moving you know
over the last five years sometimes you
need a little break down to start to
rebuild because it gives them ample
amount of time to see and understand
that they have a whole new team than
they did the previous year so how are we
gonna wear with this team so Steph being
out that helped the ktj mind thing that
helped those are all distractions for
some of these young guys and some other
people to step up or not or step down
you know and and I think that you learn
a lot you know when you're when you're a
championship team you learned a lot when
you lose alright Baron Davis and how
about the 22 wins the Raptors have with
Kawhi Leonard part of their team now and
LeBron out here out west leaves the East
wide open for the Raptors to finally
take despite the Celtics struggling
early on and the Sixers adding Jimmy
Butler when he can come back healthy and
Yanis balling out like he is in
Milwaukee what I think is you know the
asic is exciting because there's a lot
more Perry writing so there's a real
opportunity for there to be a new you
know a new contender coming out of the
East I love I love Kawhi Leonard
southern cow native and you know I just
love his energy the way they the way he
plays defense is the same way he plays
offense he gets better and better
offensively
I think the Raptors you know Pascal he's
come through NBA player of the week so
they have these young guys that and a
great mix of young guys and guys who are
right at the peak of their career and so
they have they have the the most work
and wealth Boston has the most talent
right up top to bottom they have the
most talent and they haven't put that
talent together yet and then Philly
Philadelphia is probably the scariest
right because Philadelphia adding Jimmy
Butler they actually get some stability
so when you're looking at a professional
NBA team that looks like they could be
in the championship or the Eastern
Conference Finals you're looking at a
team like Philadelphia because they can
match up with anybody and give anybody
problems now nonetheless take this third
story then the Los Angeles Lakers are
seven games above 500 yes 17 and 10
right there in the mix right there in
the middle of the Western Conference but
as Charles Barkley said at the beginning
of the season the West is much more
difficult than East there's lots more
travel in the West and there is in the
East LeBron James will not be able to
keep this pace going all year long at
his at his advancing age and the story
that came out on bleach report last week
that players are not going to want to
join LeBron Durant gave the words toxic
environment around the team because of
how much attention LeBron gets and that
other players are not going to want to
join his party or help his legacy
building when they can do it for their
own selves in this day and age what do
you make of all those you know III think
one you know being a Laker fan kudos to
the Lakers
you know I said at the beginning of the
year the Lakers should be around
somewhere between four to six outside of
LeBron the Lakers have talent right and
when you have you know and they've been
getting better you know even though it's
hard to see they've been getting better
over the last three years you look at
Brandon Ingram you look at Kuzma from
last year to this year even Lazo ball so
Josh Hart all those guys have improved
and they have the
to compete against top level talent
right they needed someone like LeBron to
come in to really start to blend that
leadership and to be the person who can
take pretty much you know the brunt of
the force from everything else yeah for
everything so they have somebody who can
stand and take you know take accept
initiate deflect all the attention and
the distractions and he's built for that
that allows these other guys to really
get better now
there's two schools of thought here
Baron Davis is that because he has the
ball in his hands all the time as Magic
Johnson said a couple of weeks ago but
we don't want to turn it into Cleveland
where that we do need to get other
people involved for sure so that despite
how talented the rest of the roster
really is they'll never really be able
to blossom because when it all comes
down to it LeBron wants the ball in his
hands in the bronze hands to down the
stretch I think for LeBron and then also
for the Lakers it's like you start
putting together the right complementary
pieces right that'll allow him to have
those stretches where you denieth the
ball and and and they can create a
machine sort of like Golden State then
you let LeBron handle the ball in spurts
and in moments down the stretch where
you know he'll be extremely effective I
think that right now LeBron has been
playing a certain way his entire career
and he's been extremely successful that
way the way the Lakers want to move and
maneuver in the future because they know
they have young talent and this young
talent can actually become more
explosive being using LeBron as a
launching pad and a springboard so
that's their that's where they're but
the meeting of the minds are gonna take
place and I think that for the Lakers is
going to be key the way that you've been
that bridge is you get the right
complement of guys you know in the
middle ground that can really support
you know what these young guys are doing
and also to help you know support LeBron
and
in what he's doing as he's getting older
I'm wondering Brockman and also Baron
Davis here if if shows like this one
existed in the late 80s early 90s and
there was a 24/7 365 sports cable
operation and Twitter and all that
will we be wondering if the rest of the
Bulls could blossom because Jordan
wanted the ball in the hands all about
the Bulls right I never heard like how's
Pippen gonna grow right you know how
scre gonna grow house house be junior
Armstrong gonna flourish right we never
we did we ever have that conversation
Jordan not once no because it's just
like Jordans the best period end of
story
damn straight he's gonna post up damn
straight he's gonna take the three who
else is gonna Pippen he's great but
really we didn't never really had that
conversation about the Bulls no and you
know what we were we were not allowed to
have those conversations right because
we allowed the players to be who they
are right and so now we're we're we're
in a league in a space where there's so
much potential right that you can
actually and there's someone's access
that you can actually like a guy for not
being a good basketball player what do
you mean I think you can just like them
we're being great on social media or a
good guy or you know have a you know or
what they do in the community or just
because you know the shoes that they
wear like you don't have you don't
necessarily have to like somebody
anymore for their game and then you also
have you know news right and you know
the media we have to like it's like
you're looking for stories you have to
find stories you have to find things to
talk about or else you just be talking
about the same thing who's the best
LeBron and Kobe Mike so I'm so so so so
so so I think that now that the game is
expanded you got guys who who look great
on the court who got dreads you know who
you know got a mohawk you know like you
can have a go
and you can suck right people like you
why it's interesting too I mean cuz to
me I think we're all just wait biding
our time til the Warriors win it anyway
I gave him the trophy the Larry French
right okay and here we are on December
12th so to that end Chris Webber was on
the official Lakers podcast called
LeBron the greatest team sport player of
all time in any team sport
he called Aloha the best player in the
history of team sports better than
making his compadres his teammates
better from his position than any
quarterback in the NFL any pitcher in
Major League Baseball I would say the
broad that's not that's not a
far-fetched statement LeBron is probably
probably has been the most responsible
for uplifting his teammates and the most
and has gotten has gotten the biggest
kind of reward with quote unquote less
talent but I just think that in his body
of work LeBron Jameses is a respected
teammate and any team that LeBron James
is on if you're on that team whether you
suck or whether you can really play and
contribute you're going to be you're
gonna have a chance to compete and and
pressure is gonna be taken off so the
you take that's the way you would go as
opposed to he wants it too much
he takes it too much the attention too
much there you go
like Durant would never join it like my
question is why would the rent won a
joint LeBron in the first place well cuz
he joins curry and everybody I mean damn
get over it that's enough be a man stand
up go out go do it you know what I mean
it's like you at the Warriors why are
you thinking about going to play for
LeBron you already you want you with the
Warriors so where would he go do you
think man you need to stay with
warriors you'll need to go nowhere
mm-hmm you know you don't need to go
nowhere but you also just use the words
play for LeBron that's his point your
honor right play for play wit it's like
why would he why would Kevin Durant
right who's just as good right and has
an opportunity
mano-a-mano to say like I can be better
why would you go and join somebody that
is already who they are because he's
done it before
that's why he's down to force a state
putting gusto but that's not that's not
you know LeBron is like no matter what
he's the top dog in the league and
everybody is like trying to like he's
the hero and the villain you know what I
mean I'm telling you that's what I'm
saying you're reading everything you can
read anything into him he's the king he
is the some people like the King some
people don't like the king right but at
the end of the day LeBron James is the
king right the Warriors they are the
champions right and so we those are the
two top dogs in the league right Steph
Curry is there Kawhi Leonard is there
Kevin Durant is there Anthony Davis is
there there are a few other guys a Greek
freakin is there so you have another you
have the next wave of guys or guys that
you know Steph Curry has Steph Curry can
brag and boast just as much as he wants
just as much as a little bran Steph
Curry is a game-changing right he's a
game changer so this next wave they
should be thinking about how can we take
out the King then join the game right um
you know that's why you know I like I
like Hawaii living like I like dudes
like that who you know he won all the
smoke he wants to he wants to challenge
I don't think that you know superstar is
just like hopping in and moving around
and you know it is it's not it's not
gonna blow well for for the league or
even for the fans
Katie need to just stay put you know he
got something special in gold estate you
know how could you get sick of losing
right how could you get sick of losing
when you have some of the greatest fans
and you're on the team with you know
Steph Curry right you can kick back and
let him and watch him you can watch Klay
time you know it's like you're
surrounded by great complementary
incredibly great basketball players and
keep it going and then keep it going all
right I want to take a break and because
I want to give the appropriate amount of
time on the show to black Santa which is
again the black Santa Company you're the
founder of that and there's a celebrity
basketball came coming up and sitting on
the Rich Eisen show green room couch
right now is black Santa and is that
missus is to see me those that's a just
for the radio audience there was that
those are mascots eyes black Santa and
mrs. Cyril yeah okay takes up the entire
couch except for the punters of people
to t-shirts me appreciate what at the
same time alright so when we when we
come back we'll discuss what this is all
about and maybe take a call or two
before Brian Regan joins us in our
number three as well don't you dare move
we went to the NFL at all Baron Davis
you know I'm in the fantasy football how
you doing are you going to playoffs this
week or what are you done no you finish
off yeah I hear you guess who I drafted
levy on bail see you later
yeah Matt yeah do you want a hug
do you need a hug over that it seems
like even right now Baron seems like you
need a hug on there what what what
leaguer you ain't who are you in with
any other players or well no no other
players just saw an honor like producers
okay artists and alright designing well
you just you everybody people who talk
smack about sports who think they know
everything about sports and I'm supposed
to be like the sports guru oh so when
you lose in that fashion and I'm like
the only one oh no did you lose to
somebody who's just like you know what I
just kind of have a feeling Derrick
Henry's gonna run for the video 279
million it's those things I'm so sorry
so thank goodness you have so much to
fall back a Raiders fan okay but I'm a
Rams fan cuz the Rams moved to LA what
could you know right so I I am allowed
to be a Rams fan always was around spam
when they were here so I can claim the
Rams there's a lot to do anything
nobody's nobody's you know well but you
know like we here and you from LA it's
like the only thing I remember are the
Raiders and the Rams mm-hm and so the LA
Raiders was like they took they took my
heart and then the Rams was like oh I
got a roof of the Rams cuz Dicker's Eric
Dickerson and all those dudes so now
it's like the Rams came back and I'm
like LA Rams that's familiar well I can
accept that the founder of the big three
as you know as being part of Three's
Company the big three cube I mean he's
mr. Los Angeles Raiders yes he what he
wanted the Raiders back here in the
worst I mean that way you know yeah
let's just hope the Raiders can turn it
around all right well so you're second
annual you wish pret presents black
Santa celebrity basketball game you were
the founder of you wish and this is
going down at the University High School
here in Los Angeles this coming Sunday
what do you
for me here it's gonna be a fun game so
we got a lot of NBA guys Metta World
Jackson Harrington Cuttino Mobley and we
got some rappers Tyga rich the kid sway
Lee from race rumors that they're
playing and you know a bunch of social
media influencers B dot a dot famous low
so usually every year what we want to do
is we we love to bring the community
together we love to bring a game where
is cheap and where we can raise money
for charity and so as a part of like
everything that we do all year you know
it's better to give there and then
receive so this is our annual charity
basketball game where we show up as
celebrities and these days everybody
donates their time and you know we
trying to raise a little money to
support the people that are you know
doing a great job in the community yep
and you go black Santa calm check it out
you can get tickets available through
that or through Eventbrite for tickets
for that again that's this Sunday
afternoon it's gonna be fun it's gonna
like last year Ice Cube was the coach
he's coaching again how was used to
coach he's a great coach we the game
went into double overtime we went on a
buzzer beater right my squat so there's
a turn to the team he beats and tells
them bye Felisha
does he do that I'm just wondering how
much Mackey talks in that I do that it's
a good game he keeps the good game going
so okay it'll be a lot a lot of fun and
Iverson showed up last year to I ever
seen was here last year Iverson was the
coast last year so he has q purses
Iverson matching necklaces and O's that
we were saying yeah I receive more like
the gym
there was no practice we know that no it
was no practice there was practice hey I
wouldn't have participated that's a lot
of fun man that's a lot of fun good for
you what do you think of the state of
UCLA hoops
I am I love the kids I love all the kids
I think that they're great they're
talented you know I think that they have
a lot of talent over there you're
picking your words I'm looking very very
lucky
about my words when it comes to UCLA you
know cuz that's that's my heart so a lot
of times I want to speak from my heart
and I gotta be you know respectful of
you know just all the elements that go
into people working hard try and do
something right correct but I will say
this UCLA basketball is you know there
has an opportunity to get back to the
golden years LA basketball and West
Coast basketball as a whole has some of
the most incredibly talented kids that
are here now which they're on that team
right and to come so UCLA should be you
know a a dominant program and it's
important for us to get back to that
dominance I by the way Baron Davis that
was a very diplomatic and uh and when
well thought out answer it sounds like
you had a tweet that you didn't want to
hit Send on right there and you were
smart enough to back off no I like Earl
Watson he's my best friend and I think
that you know guys guys who've played
their who've graduated there who care
you know there's a whole you know
there's a whole community of Bruins that
want to see you know don't want to see
that Bruins do it want to see Brewers do
it the right way well it's good to see
you sir
always great to see he's come back
anytime Baron you're damn one that was
kind I'll you put me under fire I
invited me to no games you by the way I
think your answer was well thought out
that you're going to answer it you're
part of the program you're part of the
program man how do you feel about UCLA
well you know what I think they suck I'm
a mission of God come on now I'm gonna
top I'm top five right now it's good to
see you there here's the C's Baron Davis
on Twitter again go to black Santa calm
for tickets to that awesome event coming
up the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience